welcome back to Facebook my next guest
is the lungs of the nation love that
phrase and a firm favorite of our royal
family Catherine Jenkins performed
regularly for the late Queen most
recently had a jubilee celebrations at
Windsor Castle Last Summer She's a
national treasure in her own right if
you don't believe me just ask her she'll
soon tell you she's the new Dame Vera
Lim with a unique ability to bring
people together in patriotic stuff I
couldn't think of anyone better to
perform on my show not just tonight at
the end of our interview but Catherine's
agreed to sing every night in fact she
recorded them all this afternoon in the
studio will perform at the end of every
show for the rest of the week leading up
to the coronation ending in a rousing
rendition of God Save the King Catherine
thank you no thank you for bringing your
golden Sparkle dust to the show and I
believe it's the first musical guest
you've ever had you are the first person
to sing in our studio yeah how do you
feel obviously the greatest honor of
your life
[Laughter]
time but you've also known the Royals a
long time what does this week mean to
you
well I think you know it's it's it's a
huge iconic moment
um you know it's the first coronation of
my lifetime we haven't had one for 70
years right
um as you said I've I've sung and have
met the king many times through our
um sort of shared charity work
um he presented me with my Obe award
which is a really exciting
um I think at the time I was running the
marathon so we talked about my training
comparison
well that's the thing with him he's
always so informed
um last time I saw him it was ITV three
or four years ago and he just came down
the line he was saying hello to Susanna
Reid and all these people and he got to
me anyway are you still around
but he is really funny but then we had a
good laugh about Donald Trump yeah he
wanted to know all about my interview
with Trump um yeah I've always found him
very engaging uh always got a ready quip
at hand yeah and probably the longest
apprenticeship for any job in history
right I mean he's been waiting death
decades to do this absolutely and I
think you know for those of us who have
met him with the different charity
things for example
um I worked with him on the British
forces Foundation you know you can see
that he is as I said informed but really
passionate about those things
um I think he wants to do good in the
world and and I think he has been doing
a lot of good
um you know with sustainability and
environmental issues conservation
um all of those things he cares about
and I care about and so that makes me
really happy to see the thing is it's a
bit like you following I don't know
Barbra Streisand in Vegas right in the
same theater isn't it in the sense that
he's following the greatest right the
greatest Monarch there's ever been in my
estimation his own mother and he had to
follow you know succeed if you like
after she had died I mean that's an
amazing thing to think about that it was
the loss of his mother that made him
King on a human level
so difficult to do this and it's got the
whole world watching him yeah and I but
I think that's you know that's actually
a positive is that he has uh learned you
know from her and as you said you know
she was an amazing Monarch well you had
two amazing things with her I mean you
had a lot actually you you performed
before the queen of the royal British
Legion Festival remembrance of Albert
Hall amazing
um you then sang the national anthem of
the queen of the Derby the big horse
race with her Diamond Jubilee weekend
you were chosen to sing at the Queen's
90th birthday in Windsor uh you then
performed at the Platinum Jubilee event
at Windsor Castle and that was the last
time you sang for the queen but also the
last time you saw the queen and she gave
a little wave and she went it was it was
such an emotional moment
um uh the whole the whole audience were
just so thrilled that she had been able
to attend the event well we've got a
clip of you singing I think from the
events let's take a little look at that
good
[Music]
[Applause]
I thought you've got a pair of pipes
Sonia over here
wow oh but that was at the end of the
concert she um she she her majesty drove
around and sort of give everybody a
little wave as she left and she pulled
right in front of the stage and she sort
of went oh hello Catherine and I I I
genuinely sort of welled up I thought it
was such such a lovely amazing moment
yeah it really really was very special
but that was the last time
um that I saw her sadly but I'm so
grateful for the honor of being able to
sing for her well you had another
amazing honor because when the queen
sadly died you were performing a little
event down in Sussex I think a recording
down there and you got a phone call to
tell you this this terrible news but
unlike the rest of the country who could
sort of mourn you were asked look it's
the BBC and we want somebody to record
the first version of God saved the king
what an amazing responsibility to be
asked to do that yeah
um I was in a very small beautiful rule
of church as you said with with
microphones in front of me and we get
the call to say we would like to play
this on the you see in the next hour is
it possible that you can record it and
it felt like one of those things like
this was meant to happen right here I am
I could have been anywhere but I'm
standing in a place with a beautiful
sound and microphones so um yeah we
actually stopped what we were recording
um we we said a prayer
um sort of because it felt strange to
then sing the new words and I had to
think about the new words having Always
sung it with God Save the Queen
um and we all had a little prayer and
and prayed for you know the new rain and
did you find that emotional yeah it was
really emotional
um and it was one of those my world up
when I heard the queen had died I mean
genuinely I really felt that yeah I
think we all did that kind of end of
this connection which we'd all had our
entire lives yeah absolutely and to sort
of sing it you know in that moment when
you are feeling so emotional
um but you know something clicked in and
and I sang it in one take but it was
interesting because you know every
somebody who's so used to seeing
performances and whatever the minute we
went to record it for the very first
time you know everybody's camera phones
went up and you thought oh yeah this is
this is historical yeah the first time
to ever sing these words so it was a
huge honor
did you hear from the King after that I
have not seen him at anything yet for
them you will look forward to you will
do and if you met your Miller I have I
have um
so do I I'm neighboring Villages and we
always joke about yeah she's some
pumpkin I'm a new boy or about a mile
apart and she grew up there with her
family I grew up with mine there and um
she's got that kind of earthy Southern
England local Village Spirit about it
you know down to earth No Nonsense I've
got a picture of you and her there
that's when I remember that's the very
first time I met her anyway
um we sort of hit it off I thought she
was great and
um I've sang A couple of years ago at
one of her charity um I've got her Rhino
on my wall oh
I'm the only person who owns a private
watercolor bike the woman about to be
Queen really I bought it in a charity
auction she gave it to the Daily mirrors
Charity Auction or we bought it in a
charity auction and it's a beautiful
picture of a rhino okay in the bush and
she's signed it and it's on my wall
that's amazing and every time I see her
she opened her opening line is normally
hi Pierce how's my writer which always
makes everyone's eyebrows go up
which I love I think she's great and I
know and what I really like about it she
comes from that old school of Royal Duty
which is never a complaint never explain
and rarely be heard speaking in public
three sentences you could not imagine
being regurgitated by people in
Montecito for example
[Laughter]
have you ever been invited to California
to sing for the Duke and Duchess of
Sussex and I hope I hope if you were
you'd say no
we are actually moving on to the
commercial break I'll let Catherine
sweat for a few minutes and see if
she'll answer that question after the
break or from Catherine Jenkins in a
moment plus she's going to sing for us
and that is worth definitely hearing so
definitely do that
so we're in celebration mode for the
coronation coming on Saturday Catherine
Jenkins is still with me you just told
me an amazing thing in the brain that
you are in New York at the end of this
week what are you doing on Friday I'm
going to be helping to switch the Empire
State Building into Red White and Blue
Jackets that's unbelievable I know how
fun is that did you ever think of the
little girl growing up in Wales one day
you'd be turning on the Empire State
Building not at all um it's uh it's I
think it's just going to be a really
lovely moment to start all of the
celebrations that I think are happening
Across America
um for for Brits to get involved and
celebrate even if they're not at home
now the other thing is he very kindly
gave me this as well which you didn't
ask me to promote but I like it because
it's a bottle of gin and hey I like gin
um yeah this is your new Venture Gene
yeah if you're going into the whole sort
of brandelina thing of they were the
rose and then Beckham with his whiskey
and they've all got George Clooney and
Tequila right this is the jenko what was
it Jenkins
it's called Signet yeah
um it's it's made six miles down the
road from where I grew up in in Wales
um I know it wasn't like it wasn't
something
well I I love gin I come from a family
I've seen you knock it back and I wanted
to create something that was like a
really high
um Quality Ultra Premium gin with like
all of the ingredients that I love so
for this one
um this is our Signet 22 that's got a
manuka honey in it well you did me a
massive favor why so I was doing an
audio book and if you've ever done them
they are hell on Earth you get put in a
little booth eight hours a day for days
on end I had to do four days and after
three days my voice had gone you just
talked for eight hours a day even by my
standards talking about myself this was
too much my body backed in and so I
messaged Catherine and she said I'm
sending the Cavalry did you know she
turned up at my house I mean it's a bit
stalkerish obviously but she turned up
on my house 25 minutes later
and left throat tea and Manuka honey
yeah and and you said do that and also
sip water all the time right sip water
and my voice came back yeah so you know
it's the same thing drink the Gin well
if I known that was the option it would
have made the audiobook a lot more
listenable well you know the other
option whenever you get a sore throat
peers is to go on vocal rest but I'm not
sure if that's possible I couldn't do
permanent vocal right where do you get
these pipes from when I listen to you
sing even now this is staggering the
power of your voice where did that come
from
um I don't know what did you first let
loose and think oh my god
um well when I was four I sang in public
for the first time you sang like that
when you were before no but I but I
remember there being a reaction to it
and and I was always singing because I
loved it I was never thinking about or
one day I'd like to do this business it
was just a genuine passion
um but do you think you'll know a
National Treasure is this little bit of
work no does anybody think that oh
you get wheeled out for all the big
events looking lovely and you sing
beautifully and Everyone likes you yes
I'm very proud of where I come from and
I try whenever I'm well you're going to
sing for us every night yeah uh every
night tonight you're going to sing
Britannia well Catherine Jenkins thank
you and Catherine Jenkins take it away
[Music]
thank you
when Britain first it has
foreign
[Music]
this is
when Nations
[Music]
[Applause]
with much
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]